I suspect foul play with my condo today
so here's the story woke up early hit
the gym felt great confident I'm on top
of it I'm a mature responsible adult
come back powers off waters turned off
emergency case
powers back on water still off so John
unfortunately has to deal with the scent
of Greg post Jim many hours later after
gonna need better musk we're gonna watch
the honest trailer for knives out I said
watch this and as that was in my opinion
the most clever witty script of last
year I do think parasite deserved it but
this was like the most fun oh yeah we
never reviewed it so no maybe we'll use
some jumping off points for mom's
trailers to talk about it subscribe to
screen junkies if you haven't done so
already
the following trailer was rated as for
spoilers it's a whodunit and we're gonna
tell you who did it okay so one last
time spoilers Q Popeyes
[Music]
from the director who ruined your man
childhood comes up to how I didn't act
like in the Titanic women and minorities
will take away everything you ever loved
about the new one and mute thread noise
I get ready for a brand new whodunit
vertifight number digits right I've
never met an expectation he couldn't
submerge he'll tell you who done it
right off the bat
plus we're not did and how would get
done yeah then slowly reveal who helped
done it who doesn't know about it and
why it all got getting done in the first
place
and so I loved it how done they get away
with really the swabbies airs do the
world's most sumptuous sweater
collection right these things escape
room their patriarch is Christopher
Plummer the best accurate to ever get
typecast as the world yes yes definitely
when his suicide is ruled the murder
everyone is a suspect because he spent
the night giving his entire family
reasons to kill him come on don't you
know cutting off your relatives is the
number two cause of death and rich
people fear a furnace secretary Muni
taking the case is Benoit Blanc a
detective who could really use a pigeon
spinner yeah
played by an actor who can really use a
dialect coach whoa okay we got
footprints here
he's more southern than a Confederate
plag soaked in deep-fried mint juleps
but don't underestimate this simple
country detective because he's so good
he doesn't know who's paying him who do
not know doesn't hitter knocking
witnesses for days I think you have
something you want to tell me that's the
main suspect almost dying is scared
you'll need all the help it's from a
nurse with a rare form of Bhavani I just
overlook performance a condition that
any good detective could use to crack
the case of 30 seconds
but this Hefner Sherlock can't even
smell the lies right in front of him you
know much I've been detective oh yeah
you know I'll say for a film called
knives out this saw detective job is
about as sharp as a bowling ball above a
blisters a-holes and Agatha Christie a
ride-along miss Tahlequah not really a
mystery where everyone's a red herring
and the most famous guy help do with in
the end really the only question you
have is how one housekeeper kept an
entire mansion full of knickknacks
secret passages and hid and piles of
nerve you clean get more blood elves
from ruined Johnson we make knives out
with 13 patents while you're out of the
will Frank Oz the great in power yeah
get out get out
Oh Deuteronomy Oh Kevin speaks
last VI it's makin Sigma wanted to kill
ya while clearing martyr of any
suspicion why didn't he do it in front
of anyone else in a house full of people
we wasted a real lawyers time defending
ruby jokers and hey I heard about this
to analyze Harley Quinn in our series
fandom IRL click here to see what
happens when your favorite heroes out
being polite and start getting real nice
I want to say that having fun isn't hard
when you've got a library card
hahaha cool good message great job again
team I thought this honest trailer was
like a really good SNL sketch it's
really funny in the beginning it's got a
great middle joke there
good final jokes at the end I want to
know who penned that joke in the
commentary yeah I actually think their
opening joke is rather profound because
there was like some political talk in
the film itself but the movie never
really felt like it was about politics
to me and when they pointed out you know
yak like an entitled dick women and
minorities take away your stuff for the
plate of movie perhaps up at end is that
an actual thing that ryan johnson was
going for to comment on and to some
degree i was at the way entitled rich
white people will perceive this and yeah
is it like i'm i don't know because as
the thing as you watch it the first time
you're so wrapped in like how is this
gonna go down what details do i need to
look out for and i feel like on a second
go-around you could probably then go
okay what does this character represent
right that care chris evans has to
represent the you know sort of spoiled
entitled you know manchild rich kid you
know trust fund kid they all do yeah but
but yeah like the one who's trying to
inherit the earth right now i gotta say
on ax de Armas was a completely
overlooked performance I thought she was
incredible and she's the real lead of
the movie Daniel Craig's the real male
lead but the star of the film it's
really her oh yeah it's her problem
deep down at least we in the plot and
she's so good they did bring up some
good little nitpicks here I thought why
didn't Christopher Plummer off himself
in front of other people that way there
was no questions about it or at least
when she was like long gone
yeah in any position to vomit the answer
for anybody a big part of why I thought
this movie was brilliant was a
subversion of the whodunit there are
some people I've met who actually have a
major gripe with the handling of that
because the way the trailer sets you up
is the expectation of a whodunit and
then early on in the film they show you
oh he did just kill himself they show
exact situation pretty much right off
the bat it's like making a negative of a
whodunit where it's like the only part
you're certain about is who what and
where and then all the rest is a mystery
around it yeah and I thought that was
great because by the time he do get to
the end feel like some people are able
to predict that it was Chris Evans who
did do it don't know anyone who was able
to really pinpoint how he did it beyond
his shadow of adèle I feel like Chris
Evans was involved somehow he's
responsible maybe he's the one who paid
shirt but it's a whole other subject to
be like no he definitely switched the
bottles around into this and that he you
know like that yeah I don't know anyone
who actually went that far
into figuring it out and you do have a
bunch of other like this at red herrings
basically you have a whole bunch of
reasons to suspect a lot of other people
so I feel like there's a lot of that
mental math that can get in the way
basically a lot of doubt that can keep
up through that it's funny I guess I'd
have to go back through the film you
know with Benoit Blanc especially not
being a very good detective I want to go
back to the villain see if that's like
truly the point of his character is just
to be sort of ineffectual and yet
somehow solving this mystery because
there are aspects of like why did he
wait to talk to this person that felt
maybe a little a little nitpicky in this
trailer but then again looking back
maybe I am being a little too forgiving
or something like that you know well I
think on his trailers they have to
nitpick you know they got to get their
jokes in there
you know to get a stab like I listen to
the reviews of the screen junkies team I
can tell when they're poking fun at
stuff as opposed to this is a real issue
I think dan Merle would have brought it
up in his review who has one of the head
writers the punch trailers I think he
would have definitely brought up he
praised the hell out of Daniel Craig
you really had an issue with the
character I think he would have brought
it up and been like you notice smart is
it the movie wants me to think he is out
of context it's easy to go he almost
like an hour must died a couple of times
yeah when you slice it together like
this it's really funny and it's true
yeah but there's a whole other but very
surrounding apparently there is a sequel
that's been greenlit for this but I
think I think it's just a different
adventure for Daniel Craig's character
that's what in Johnson said yeah nobody
else is returning except Ben wobbling
they see it to me that's the exact
expectation I would have for a knives
out sequel so Rian Johnson you're not
doing your job
that's right you got to bring it back to
the same family now there's another
murder take Daniel Craig out of it turns
out he did it yeah he's also dead now
subvert expectations there's no way by
fulfilling our expectation and say yeah
that's right that's right as long as
they're not exactly a little bit came
before it's still a subversion exactly
yeah we know how to properly do this we
know how to subvert we can subvert
things guys what do you think it knives
out the cast in this film brilliant
everyone's amazing in it I love the way
it's shot it's colorful edited it's just
like the the filmmaking is really
exciting in that movie and what's cool
is that even though it is inspired by
Agatha Christie like novels those
whodunits from back then it's still an
original film it made over a hundred
million dollars at the box I miss oh
yeah and you don't really see that as
often anymore no and I'm surprised just
because of the Eyre like Rian Johnson's
name has become a lot higher profile
because the Eyre that followed the last
Jedi so if the fact that people really
turned out for this like really makes me
oddly happy just had to find that middle
ground you had those like smaller films
like brick and looper yeah and there's
bloom did he jump straight Star Wars
yeah and now he's in the middle when
dives out and this is the right ground
for the guy maybe he can keep that
shrinking middle budget film alive
alright guys well what do you think of
knives out leave your thoughts down
below subscribe to screen junkies if you
haven't done so already subscribe to
rejects cook I notification bail last
but not least well let's end this with a
Eric Horstman I wrote you a poem a
message from Eric can be quite frantic
maybe a cynic but when I meet him in
public I will give him a kiss wearing
lipstick
we'll ride in the night and a chariot s
he booked us a suite at the Marriott get
him and I did that give you work yep
fights for the rights of the animals I
received light from this white night
reasons for my arousal 'he's the
sadistic humor of a henchman his last
name be it Horstman love his stories
from being a freshman because he told me
sort of be not yep the man filled with
virtue got a real rejects tattoo now
we're imprinted never ever have to say I
bid you adieu and he's gay he's gay
yeah like super EK gayest